manque de communication absence de
dialogue social mépris face aux salariés
telles sont les revendications de la cgt
de la poste
seraient concernées les sites de
courriers de montigny elancourt maurepas
trappe et magny les hameaux
lundi matin une dizaine d'employés s'est
réunie devant le bureau de saint quentin
en yvelines
on est peu nombreux présents là ce matin
apparemment par contre il y aurait un
taux de grévistes assez important mais
bon les camarades ont eu énormément de
pression et ont eu peur de se déplacer
le problème qui se pose sur cette
réorganisation la met sur toutes les
autres dans le département et au niveau
national c'est la bonne chose
on reproche en fait à la poste de
redémarrer ses réorganisations sans
prendre part à ce que la commission
caspar qui est une commission qui a eu
pour but de mettre en évidence certaines
choses qui se passent pas bien on
voudrait nous que ce soit bien remis sur
la table et qu'on reprenne les charges
de travail reprend l'humain pour
illustrer les dysfonctionnements qu'ils
évoquent les syndicats pointent du doigt
la réorganisation du bureau de poste de
magny les hameaux
le bureau de magny les hameaux va être
délocalisée sur saint rémy les chevreuse
les collègues qui travaillent sur
manille vont être donc rattaché au
bureau de saint rémy et auront pour
aller travailler sur leur tournée de
manille environ 15 minutes de trajet
supplémentaire pour aller sur leur
tournée et 15 minutes pour revenir à peu
près ça c'est pas intégré dans leur
temps de travail
le bureau d'elancourt lui aussi
connaîtra quelques changements puisqu'il
sera relocalisée sur mon repas le bureau
d'elancourt doit aussi le 20 novembre
comme manny être délocalisés sur mon
repas il faut savoir que les facteurs à
l'origine il ya huit ans était déjà sur
mon repas et qu'on les a déplacés à
elancourt aujourd'hui huit ans après on
les ramène sur mon repas avec un site
qui n'est pas conforme
ils ont fait des travaux certes dedans
mais
il est apparu des fissures sur des murs
des choses comme ça c'est un site qui
est trop petit pour accueillir tout le
monde pour travailler dans des
conditions décentes la poste que nous
avons contactés a répondu aux différents
points évoqués
le déménagement du bureau de magny les
hameaux permet un rapatriement vers une
plate forme récente mieux adapté aux
exigences de production du côté de
maurepas le site a subi des travaux de
réaménagement il ya tout juste un an il
répond donc aux normes actuelles quant
au manque de communication dénoncé par
la cgt la poste des yvelines explique
que des plénières avec les agents et les
organisations syndicales sont
régulièrement organisés et comme insiste
la direction l'écoutent individuel est
une option possible